double murder trial of Alex murdaugh
resumes in South Carolina this morning
the once prominent attorney is accused
of shooting his wife and son to Death in
June of 2021. he has pleaded not guilty
prosecutors rested their case last last
week 20 days after jury selection began
Nikki Batiste is in South Carolina with
what we can expect from the defense
Nikki good morning
good morning the prosecution wrapped up
his case after calling more than 60
witnesses to the stand and presenting
more than 500 pieces of evidence the
defense is out to show that none of it
directly ties Murdoch to the crime
the defense in the Alex Murdoch trial is
expected to continue trying to poke
holes in the prosecution's case this
week this is one of the things we do
sometimes to try and estimate a time of
death is is the body cold is the body
warm last Friday attorneys called
Colleton County coroner Richard Harvey
as their first witness and raised
questions about the time of death for
murdaugh's wife Maggie and Son Paul
concluded on your death certificate nine
o'clock
that's strictly an estimation that's a
guess that's a guess okay it could have
been 8 30. could have been 8 30. could
have been 10 o'clock there were no
witnesses there to tell me exactly what
time this happened CBS News legal
analyst Ricky cleeman so what the
defense is trying to do is say look how
can you possibly convict this man when
even a coroner doesn't know the precise
time of death and it's a two and a half
hour window the prosecution has argued
that Murdoch was at the scene right
around the time his wife and son were
murdered how long did it take for that
less than 20 seconds in fact their Final
witness was special agent Peter rodofsky
of the South Carolina law enforcement
division he testified data from
Murdoch's Chevy Suburban showed he drove
right by the location where his wife's
phone was found the following day a
quarter mile from the crime scene and
sped up from 42 miles per hour to 45 5
miles per hour as he passed the defense
was quick to question that is it fair to
say he's continuing a fairly gentle
acceleration
I would say so yes
Murdoch's legal team told me they're
considering putting him on the stand to
notable defense Witnesses we expect to
testify our Murdoch's surviving
sunbuster and one of Murdoch's Brothers
both have been sitting behind him in
court every day Tony
all right Nikki thank you very much